my mom is my best friend Linda and she's
completely selfless she volunteers
thousands of hours in her community and
she was diagnosed with terminal breast
cancer and given two years and that was
four years ago
so she's still offense you know she's
raised us kids and I promised her that
when she beats it we're gonna take her
to see Reba and that's the goal of ours
but she's really sick so having you
seeing it as an excess thing because we
absolutely love you and thank you so
much two years and it's been four yes
she's one hell of a fighter yes she
absolutely is that's a beautiful thing
for years they gave her too she's she
got this yeah
[Applause]
I don't know yeah well tell me a little
bit more about your mom they're like why
is she's such a big Reba van um she's
just always raises on country music and
growing up in the car at home she's
always play to Reba for us so we've just
always grown up with the music and she's
huge on country so I'm huge on country
huge on Kelly and so um yeah just be
singing it was really big for her okay
well I love your mom she's awesome so
what's your mom like is she fun like you
oh she's tons of fun I could tell you
stories but it'd probably not probably
biggest and perfect yes and we have
get-togethers at the house and she hosts
for the holidays and all the parties and
she's amazing right she's so much fun
even even though she's sick she makes
sure that she's the life of the party as
best as she can be and she still does
everything for everybody else even
though she's going through it she's
going through everybody else comes first
[Applause]
you know to Reba but I think your mom
deserves the best so please welcome
country legend no I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this